alors il ya eu les kaïra shopping et
puis il ya eu le film les cailleras et
vous êtes h et une porsche souvenez
l'aïe a validé la série deuxième saison
déjà est ce que vous vous êtes fixés
d'en faire plusieurs des saisons jusqu
où et est ce qu'on peut imaginer le film
et du coup ce sera quoi un avion
alors ça rapporte pas autant d'argent de
fer mais non mais en fait avec
l'histoire de la porsche
alors pour tout vous dire puisque on est
entre nous la sueur sur les caméras
c'est vrai je m'étais fait un challenge
je m'étais dit si jamais le film il est
un million ce qui était totalement
inespéré fokam se remet dans le contexte
de ce petit film que je fais avec pas
beaucoup de moyens hamelin
dans le quartier d'où je viens avec mes
potes se dire que ça allait faire un
million d'entrées que ça allait partir à
cames que ça allait être le film le plus
rentable de l'année c'était inespéré
donc je m'étais mis ce petit défi fou un
peu ridicule de me dire si le film faire
un million d'entrées je m'achèterai une
porsche qui est mon fantasme de mecs de
banlieue quoi qui a vu des porsche dans
les clips de rap toute sa jeunesse et le
film affermie au contraire donc je me
suis acheté une petite porsche et puis
ensuite quand on l'a fait pattaya j'me
sicile film il fait 2 millions grille je
m'achète une lamborghini et le film a
fait 2 millions et tout ça ça met un peu
passé donc j'ai acheté leur ligne et
j'avais vraiment l'air d'un con avec par
lamborghini dans paris être en
protestant si compliqué c'était vraiment
compliqué puisque enfin le plus discret
mais voilà c'est des trucs
j'ai rappelons que c'était des cases à
cocher quoi les marqueurs ouais franck
on va regarder quelques images également
de votre vie mais en se déplaçant du
côté du fauteuil qu'ils se trouvent